make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so we're getting back into New Mutants
and New Mutants is the absolute best
thing coming out of Marvel Comics right
now and this is the craziest thing right
oh by the way for those of you guys who
want to see my uncensored videos and
those of you guys who actually want to
see videos I think the next one we're
doing if superboy-prime versus Franklin
Richards and then I think after that
we're doing superboy-prime vs. Matthew
Molloy if you want to see the vs. videos
head over to patreon write the
uncensored videos are like a dollar a
month and the vs. videos are like 5
bucks right so it's not like an arm and
a leg or anything it's pretty cool stuff
but New Mutants is amazing it's it's
absolutely stellar so in the first video
that we did we had basically talked
about how the the New Mutants was more
or less being reformed with the
exception of Sam Guthrie right Sam Groth
he was one of the original members of
the New Mutants and where the team was
being reformed they were actually being
reformed for the purpose of going on a
mission to see our space in order to
save Sam and bring him back and the
indication was that he was he was in
jeopardy the issue with this is that
when they were able to book passage with
the starjammers of course led by Corsair
who's the father of Scott Summers and
the starjammers are basically space
pirates more or less what they ended up
discovering is that the starjammers
actually intended to steal an artifact
and so the result was that the the New
Mutants got involved and ultimately they
were arrested for the stealing of this
artifact when everything went south the
starjammers made off with it and then
they were taken before the court of the
Shiar now here's the thing the court of
the Shiar is intense right like Marvel's
shown this multiple times over the years
dear hardcore right like the lawyer
who's basically a spate like a Marvel
Comics version a better call Saul is
basically what he is which is amazing on
let me if you guys watch that show but I
love Saul Goodman in Breaking Bad and
better call Saul has always been solid
but the lawyer basically tries to plead
the case that like because the New
Mutants are from Earth they don't really
know she our customs or how anything
works there and so they should
essentially be pardoned like it he
basically takes the guys takes all of
them and throws him before the courts
mercy and the response of the judge is
like are we in Earth's space or are we
in Shiar space and the lawyers like
we're in Shiar space and the judge is
like that's what I thought
guilty and it's like we don't care where
they're from they broke our laws and
that's just the way it's gonna go so
they're basically like this carries a
lifetime sentence you're gonna be handed
over to the Shiar officials and they're
gonna decide what they want to do for
you only for us to find out that the be
handed over to Sam Guthrie and to super
guardian the Smasher Isabelle Cain this
is kind of funny right because like we
really know what was going on with Sam
Guthrie when he was out here apparently
he's doing pretty good for himself and
it kind of makes sense I don't know if
any of you guys know who's super
guardian is she was a character who was
introduced during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers of New Avengers but basically
Isobel Kane is is really one of the very
few instances when I'm when I say phew I
mean like you can count them on one hand
the very few instances where an
Earthling is actually inducted into the
Shiar Imperial Guard the Shiar Imperial
Guard is basically this this elite
fighting force composed of like the most
powerful or worthy beings throughout the
entirety of Shiar space right so the
Shiar only really brings in those who
were part of the Shiar empire going as
far as to bring somebody in from earth
was actually a pretty big deal the
nature of Isabel Kane is she has what
are called X's specs I think is what
they're called but basically it's those
those red looking glasses she has when
she puts those on they give her the suit
that she has along with like
super-strength with speed durability she
can fly through space without needing
some kind of an oxygen take it gives her
all the all the things that she needs
she's pretty capable and she's pretty
daggone powerful she's a big-time heavy
hitter during the events of time runs
out which basically had that eight month
gap between really when the multiverse
was collapsing and like what it all
started to basically wind down when the
multiverse was coming to an end Sam
Guthrie and Isabel Kane actually ended
up getting together they had a kid
together got married that kind of a
thing and they've basically been
together ever since right so that's why
you see the two of them together here
but it's kind of a cool little thing
right because like it's like this
basically this is really huge coming
together and the return of the New
Mutants and Sam Guthrie is just as goofy
as he ever was like how did you know we
were here
he's like well I actually planted a
tracking devices behind your ears the
reality was that the space lawyer called
him but this is this is cool right so
for old-school fans of New Mutants it's
a return to form and that's what makes
dawn of X so cool is this like a return
to the to the way x-men are supposed to
be right like each title is individual
and each title feels unique right it has
his own own style of storytelling is
telling his own various adventures it's
awesome right and this feels like
old-school New Mutants right like the
hipster comic book fans or the really
old comic book fans will probably attest
to this like it feels like old-school
New Mutants and it works right it's that
great blend of comedy and seriousness
and so the result of this is that with
them basically being handed over to Sam
Guthrie and a super guardian the issue
then comes in the play where super
guardian is contacted by gladiator now
remember gladiator is the current ruler
of
she our Empire and it's cool right
because but what he basically says is
the Shiar empire is in need of your aid
you've all been conscripted here's your
mission go carry it out now remember the
nature of the Shiar Empire especially
under the rule of a gladiator isn't
really like dark like gladiators not a
dick Riley felt like a terrible leader
or anything it's not like ruling with
like an iron fist but it's one of those
things where you don't disrespect the
throne and that was even the case with
with light eater himself when he was
leader of the Imperial Guard but he
wouldn't defy the orders of the Emperor
or the Empress but if they were order
she disagreed with he would kind of try
to find a way to skirt them it was it
was it was an interesting little thing
like I believe the laundry was alive at
the time yeah the laundry was alive
during the rise of Vulcan the third
summers brother when he started trying
to like take over the Shiar empire and
so initially I believe that Vulcan
tasked gladiator with executing lilandra
in his stead he basically escorted her
out of she arch space got her out of
there and basically had her live in
exile ultimately she died but had it
live in exile for time or at least tried
to help her escape so he was kind of
like skirting
right like skirting the rules more or
less but the reason why they've all been
conscripted here is because when super
guardian shows up when when Isabel Kane
shows up she's like all of you guys are
gonna be serving on our behalf all of
the guys are gonna be working for us and
here's the reason why but before we get
an explanation we end up jumping to
gladiator who's meeting with Zondra
Zondra is basically the daughter of
lilandra near Imani and Charles Xavier
were the two of them having a lot of
interest yeah I know Charles Xavier is
having kids all over the place man it's
nuts like for a guy who can't walk he's
having a whole lot of kids I understand
how that works it's kind of nuts man
Charles Xavier gets around
but Zondra despite how young she looks
she is a hoss she is a force to be
reckoned with she's basically an
omega-level character her power
basically allows her to tap into the
minds of others it works on a universal
scale right so like anybody in the
universe she can tap into their mind and
basically dominate their mind dominate
and control them so imagine Charles
Xavier but like if he could reach out to
the universe it's ridiculous how
powerful she is like it's one of those
characters like Marvel never really does
anything with its nuts
where her character resides now
admittedly when I say Marvel never
really does anything with her a lot of
that's probably because of the fact that
she didn't really show up until mr. and
mrs. x number two I think it was in
October of 2018 so she's been around for
like a year right so like not long
enough to do anything with so I guess
I'm kind of being a little overly harsh
on Marvel but
kind of a cool thing because what's
really happening here and this is a very
easy thing to overlook but it's very
important what's happening here is the
response of a gladiator is the Shiar
Empire needs to have an era money on the
throne meaning Zondra needs to become
the new leader of the Shiar essentially
with Alondra not being there is kind of
starting to cycle all over again right
because she's a spitting image of her
mom as though it's the cycle starting
all over again that Emir Imani is taking
over the throne gladiator is stepping
down as Magister and going back to being
the prey tour of the Imperial Guard
basically the leader of the Imperial
Guard it's returning the Shiar landscape
back to the way it was under Chris
Claremont and it's a pretty significant
thing we end up finding out the reason
why this is the case is because of the
fact that basically death bird is trying
to find a way to make our way back to
ruling the Shiar Empire death for being
a sister of Alondra and exceedingly
dangerous it's cool if you don't really
care about the x-men or the Shiar this
doesn't really matter you it's coming I
mean that's cool but if you're like me
you're this awesome man it's pretty
sweet and I'm very very excited about it
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are no here to comment explain and make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob fort if you guys
want to see my uncensored and vs. videos
head over to patreon comments explained
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace I want to give a shout out
to Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B we have a lot of
Austin's and our patreon as well as G
gnosis 916 de gnosis didn't give us a
first and last name so we kind of had to
roll with it I didn't mention your last
names I thought you guys didn't want me
to throw them out there but I want to
say thank you to you all by the way your
rob4 rings should be on their way for
our honor guard members of the rob corps
for these special patrons your custom
rob4 rings should be on their way
they're being shipped to me after that I
will have them shipped to you stay tuned
keep your eye on patreon and your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you
[Music]